whatever you you thought happened to
this victim you were ending act one with
a oh no that's not it there's a big
question mark there's way more to this
story than I thought
what happens in act one of a crime drama
act one of a crime drama so much happens
right so we're meeting everybody all our
main characters protagonists hero
um
or sorry antagonist protagonists we're
meeting our victim we're meeting people
surround that surrounded the victim or
meeting a few just a few we're setting
up the tone we're setting up the world
we're setting up the why why this crime
why this person why this investigator
maybe even why this criminal or at least
we're setting up those questions because
there's different ways you can tell
there's four kind of ways you can tell a
crime story so we're setting up the
basics of all that
we are getting into some clues that are
going to be false so we'll give or get
we're getting a few hints as to maybe
how and why this person died
um a couple of those are not going to
pan out meetings different suspects a
couple new you know the kind of the
preliminary Persons of Interest and
um then by the end of act one we're sort
of crushing that
um for our detective and I use the
detective as any you know any person
who's investigating where this person
thinks they know what's happening with
with the crime or they think they're on
the right track and it's going to get
blown out of the water and so when when
they launch into act two they're gonna
have to come up with a whole new
and this way of of trying to go about
this
what are the best ways to introduce
detectives
oh the best ways
so individual right depending on who
that character is
um
but I
I like to when I'm first trying to
create
a protagonist I I want to know what
their secret is their pet peeve
what kind of Quirk they have I want to
know what devil they have to fight and I
want to know their strengths and their
weakness so I'm trying to put all that
into when I'm introducing them within
that First Act
um
those are just kind of my my checklist
and then of course we go deeper into all
that but
I think if we can hit all that we're
we're doing pretty good and we're
showing our audience that hey this is
somebody we haven't seen before this is
kind of interesting
and then at some point we would do the
same with the antagonist at some point
yes yep and that can get rolled out a
little bit more slowly and it can get
rolled out through the eyes of the crime
as well
so even if we don't beat our antagonist
for a while we start to get a feeling or
of what kind of person this is you know
based on how they committed the crime
evidence maybe that was left behind on
what people are saying about the victim
and maybe people that the victim knew so
how does act one end
act one
I think it needs to end with a bit of
frustration for the protagonist a bit of
suspense
um definitely a question mark this
whatever you you thought happened to
this victim you were ending act one with
a oh no that's not it there's a big
question mark there's way more to this
story than I thought
kind of a question mark
and could that also be in terms of um
access like whether it's the POV of a
family member or or or a detective that
they think that the access to solve
something or get information those doors
are closed yes it could be the closed
doors of access it could be the closed
doors of a piece of evidence they
thought was key you know we're gonna you
know this is it we're going to figure it
out
um it can be meant yeah any of those
things maybe they even have a suspect in
custody and then nope The Alibi pans out
and
they're off now we're at we're back at
square one
what are the major beats of act two in a
crime drama
they they're honestly really the same as
any other type of script you're going to
follow the same beats like I'm very much
a save with the cat kind of writer I I
use that as the skeleton of my story I
follow all those beats except that when
I'm laying out the actual case those
beats always pertain to my case and my
crime
and my protagonist so
um you know we we're going to start the
beginning of act two
with we're gonna have to go over go
after all new evidence and all new
people to talk to you because it just
didn't pan out in act one by the
midpoint it looks like we may have
somebody okay we it's all kind of coming
to a nice little head of of I think we
got the person we're looking for and
then by the end of act two everything's
crumbled
so and not just crumbled like this is
all not panning out we are not on the
right track but are now by the end of
act two that kind of all hope is lost
moment our investigators life is being
threatened they may it looks like not
only are they going to lose the case but
now they're going to lose their life
they've been kidnapped they've been
injured they're being held up whatever
however you want to do it they're not
going to get it they're not going to get
this case solved that's so really
follows the same but just
case all all about the case
how common is it for at least one
suspect to Disappear by the second act
by the end of the first suspect to just
like like die disappear or maybe they've
just kind of been ruled out like you
said their Alibi checks out and or or
you know whatever it is right but I mean
by the end of act two you should
probably have three to four suspects who
have not checked out who have are done
like you're you're gonna run run through
three to four
um because by the beginning of act three
your investigator is going to regroup
and get themselves back on the right
track and oh wait now I figured out
who's really the real person now we need
to go after that person
um and then maybe they figured it out
who knows they may have figured out some
of that before but they can't quite get
there so act three is about actually
getting the real
um killer but you're gonna dispose of
probably three or four before you get to
the the real one
and how important is it to reach the
wrong solution in act three
um
act three I don't believe is really
about reaching the wrong solution
um I think it's more about because
you've already had a chance to do that
in one and two or you should be doing
that and wanted to by act three you're
coming up with a final battle plan now
you've got it kind of figured out and
it's really more about that battle plan
and executing that battle plan to really
go in and get
the real killer the real
um suspect
so it becomes more about
um figuring out that plan executing that
plan there may be some you know up and
down in that plan it looks like it's you
know there's a little bit of tension and
or a lot of tension in act three but
it's more about actually
tart honing in your Target on the real
um criminal and getting them how
important is it to have an overlooked
clue yes there should be I think because
you don't want your hero to be
uh
super smart you want to be super smart
but you want them to be human and humans
we Overlook things so I do think there
should be you know it's not act one is a
nice place like that by the end of act
one by the somewhere in act two is
always a nice place sometimes it can
even happen in act three where all of a
sudden you know something comes to light
that they hadn't considered before or
that wasn't present before or whatever
the reason however you get it there
um that that can be part of their their
final plan or oh we we didn't see that
before and now that helps us connect all
these pieces and now we know how to
catch the Killer
so
must there always be a confrontation in
act three yeah
yeah yep I it's we're talking about
fold good and evil here this is like
crime is you know good versus evil and
so yes there always has to be
uh
that battle right between good versus
evil because again we're talking about
the world of chaos and Injustice and
um that has to be righted so it's gonna
be a battle Good and Evil
and how do we know we have a satisfying
ending
I don't know where I satisfied ending
we know we have a satisfying ending when
whatever
chaos or
Injustice was set up at the beginning is
now ordered is now righted is now
somehow redeemed
um and this happens even in Capers um
even when the bad guy wins or loses in
Capers because you're whatever you're
setting up it even I'm I keep thinking
of hell or high water because there's
this really bad Injustice that's set up
at the beginning with the mother of
these two brothers and by the end uh
the criminals who are our bad guys these
brothers but we're rooting for them
right they do this thing this criminal
activity and even though um
there's a big sacrifice that happens big
sacrifice that happens to one of them
the mother's situation is righted it's
restored and so there always is a
sacrifice right there's always some sort
of sacrifice that happens but we know
it's satisfying because whatever was set
up at the beginning is this is not right
this is chaos this is we need this
redeemed that thing is redeemed at the
end
so whether it's big or little